back in july we revealed the new
direction of skull and bones and since
then the team at ubisoft singapore has
been hard at work getting the game ready
for launch let's take a deep dive into
the world of skull and bones
the end of the 17th century
when ruthless corporations ruled the
seas with an iron fist
they ignited a battle for global
supremacy
to dominate the world's most valuable
trade rules
a flood of exotic goods from the indian
ocean stormed the west
creating new addictions
and a violent race for control
and where there's blood
there are predators
labeled as enemies of all mankind
this new breed of pirates will show no
mercy
sailing through dangerous waters
they created secret trading networks and
built their pirate empires
but they were always on the edge of
losing it all
and sinking to the depths
as skull and bones
will you sing to the bottom or climb to
the very top in the dangerous wall of
screenbones everything around you is
either your prey or you don't fall this
is where you and your friends will have
an authentic parrot experience
in our game as your own family begins to
spread across the indian ocean you will
gain access to your own parrot layer
known as the helm
here you'll kick start your stand as a
parading pin by manufacturing and
smuggling illegal and high value goods
to sell to the highest bidder no longer
taking orders from other parrots you'll
now be the one calling the shots but
with all the riches now for you taking
you'll also have more to lose so beware
the vultures are circling abiding their
time to strike you down will you fend
off parrot rugs eyeing your cargo as you
extract your control bond or undone
rivals who want a piece of your pie
maybe you'll plan their farts for their
stockpiles and flood the black markets
or even go on treasure ends to dig up
valuable hidden stashes we've been
gathering your feedbacks through our
insider programs and other channels
it's an ongoing process that helps us
shape skull and bones
here is what some of our participants
have to say about the program
greetings pirates captain flynn here my
name's sam more commonly known as mr
stainless i'm brielle dane and i'm fuzzy
boy my name is spammers my name's hippo
tc my name is mixelplix this is veda
drum charging charlie crispy tater tot
here i joined the skull and bones
insider program back in 2021 i've
actually been part of the insider
program ever since its inception i've
sailed blundered and pillaged my way
through multiple testing and feedback
sessions the play tests that i've been
doing have been a lot of fun one of the
things that i enjoy about it the most is
the streamlined feedback actually
reaching the developers the developers
are passionate about this game i get to
connect with other gamers who are just
as passionate and excited about skull
bones as i am happy to see the game
being revealed again i'm so excited
we're just months away i look forward to
seeing your sales out there i truly
think there's something for everyone so
i'm really eager to see all the polish
and final versions of things brought
into the game i just can't wait to see
all the in the oceans and i'm really
looking forward to seeing all of you out
on the high seas be it friend or foe
a parrot's work is never done
as your fleet grows so will our game as
in the parrot tales of old you will
always find a ship at the center of the
story one so terrifying that most will
fly on site
that is what we want for our parrots
your ship is your entire world it is
where your success will be decided and
how you will be recognized
in skull and bones to build a unique
ship that inspires fear onto your
enemies
there are three steps
step one
pick your weapons and ammo this will
make or break your battles
from pursuing ammo that ignores armor
and causes floating to tearing armor
that rips your enemy cells apart slowing
them down for an easy kill my favorite
is crushing at it deals a devastating
blow to most armor step 2
choose your armor with our games weapon
counter system there will be an armor
that can counter each damage type that's
how we keep tension high at sea
lastly it's the look of your ship put on
your scariest war paint and head out
with a sheep that is instantly
recognizable making this quick
adjustment will transform you from
sneaky smuggler to hard eating hunters
or swift traders
now when you are out in the open sea
it's always best to have a friend or two
to watch your back
in our pvp world you can choose to
switch off pvp to prevent any friendly
fire as well
lastly
our game will be cross players launch
so you can parat with your friends no
matter what platform they are on
ultin zen
and
bon
voyage
all soon on the seas of scotland bones
this could be the greatest heist ever
[Music]
and you kali will play the villain
your ship
[Music]
purge your loins
and seize that [ __ ] convoy
destiny is calling
our names on her lips
oh